rival gangs are battling for control of
Haiti's Capital putting hundreds of
thousands of people at risk in a city
where authorities are struggling to
restore order United Nations is saying
that at least 99 people have been killed
recently in just one neighborhood seat
Soleil from January to June the U.N
documented nearly a thousand killings
and almost 700 injuries along with 680
kidnappings this again was in the
capital Port-au-Prince
last month was particularly bad 234
people were killed or injured over just
five days between the 8th and 10th of
July
all right well joining me now is Louis
Ori Maz who is the head of La culapia
peace building organization that runs
Community projects for young Haitians he
joins us now from the outskirts of the
capital and I might just start by asking
you then about what's happening in seat
Soleil this is the the besiege
neighborhood in Port-au-Prince where
people don't have access to water
electricity or Healthcare is anything
being done to get a humanitarian Aid
into the area or to get people out
well thank you for having me on your
show uh there is a attempt by uh some
parties uh connected with uh
humanitarian relief to discuss uh with
the gang's access to the hardest hit
part of City Soleil however it's not
been
um start moving it's not been moving uh
very fast and uh these shoes are still
um on uh on a Battlefront is still going
on between the the war in gangs in the
Soleil so uh the people cannot get out
they cannot come in and relief is not is
not available for the people inside City
Soleil right now and there's no water
there's no food and in order to get out
you have to go through uh both uh
battling gangs and uh it's not uh it's
not an option right now for the people
in in the area so if they try to get out
they'll just be hitting the crossfire I
am yes uh and the crossfire is uh at
random and it will not take into
consideration if you're civilian or if
you are in a warrior so uh it is a dire
situation and uh there is uh no
intervention that we can see from the
government or from the police forces in
order to stop this situation from going
on
why is the intervention not working
the uh the interests of our play are not
known there is a few people that have
access
to the real interests that are at play
in the world Soleil there is uh
um probably issues that have to do with
uh territory control of territory for uh
the next elections
um the whole war in Port-au-Prince in
the different neighborhoods has to do
with preparing the ground for the next
elections so the people who control the
territory will be able to sell votes to
the political parties that are going to
be vying for the different positions in
the next elections and uh so it's the
links between the politicians and the
the gangs and those that are doing the
fighting uh and the need to use that for
leverage in in the upcoming election
that has kept this fighting going
yes I believe so I believe so there is a
need to take into consideration the
human cost of these wars and it's not
being done by uh whether the government
or the gangs themselves of course
but for people in seat Soleil this is
not new the area has suffered from years
of gang violence
who are the people involved in the
fighting now we see back we speak about
gangs and armed groups who who is it
specifically that is engaging in this
fighting
on one side there's uh the the j9
condition of gangs that's fighting
against uh Gabriel who has its own
Coalition called the J-pop and um they
are at each other's throats they've been
at each other's throats for a number of
years now there was a truce for about
three years but uh about a couple of
years ago it started uh the fight
started again
well thank you very much for joining us
John orimaz I do appreciate you taking
the time
thank you